اهلا وسهلا بكم في حوار فرانس 24
فيها مباشره همم ما بقدر اعطيك همم تاريخ
لانه الموضوع مرتبط مش بس بقطع بطاقه ثاني
احوال الطقس يعني القطاع المالي والقطاع
المصاري في اللي بيمنع الاستثمارات وهمم
الوضع الاقتصادي في البلد والوضع السياسي
بالبلد
والموقف او المواقف التي تاخدها الدول من
حولنا ان كانت دول الشقيقه او الدول
المستعان
بس دايما في شروط
الغاز من النصر والاردن لم تعد به
الولايات المتحده من يعطل ذلك
الموضوع همم اعلن عنه ممكن جزء من من
رغبتي ان يشارك بالحكومه لانه انا سمعت في
بدايه الطريق في صيف 2021 قالت السفيره
همم الامريكي وقتها انه في حل له مشكله
الطاقه في لبنان عبر الغاز المصري
والكهرباء الاردني والحقيقه انا شفت هناك
نوع من الناقوس امال بيسموه او مش ناقوس
مثل همم
وقلت لحالي نستفيد من هذه الفرصه ونبني
عليها لانه اذا علي ووفاق وطني واذا في
دعم اجنبي
ممكن كثير احقق اه وهي بتاعتي اا ساعات
جديده كهرباء للبنانيين ارخص بكثير من ما
يدفعون على المولدات الخاصه سالتك سالتني
انت مين انا ما ما ما ما بعرف شغله بعرف
انه البنك الدولي هو نصف المفروض في ممول
ال- ال- الموضوع الغاز وتكهرب الاردني
والمفروض بالاسره الدوليه بقياده ال- همم
الاداره الامريكيه واداره الخزينه همم انه
الخزانه انه يامن همم بشكل مكتوب وخطي همم
رايي نهائي بعدم وجود اي تداعي تسلبيه
لقانون قيصر على هذه الاتفاقيه بن شروط
اللي وضعه لنا اياها باول الطريق في السيف
والخريف 2021 انه كيلو الامور
وكله تم عينيها ويمكن اذكر الاهم فيها هي
اصلاح الاعطال في الخطوط ان كان الكهرباء
من قبل الاخوان بسوريا وهي قاموا في يكلف
معه دولار وان احنا من جهت سلاح خط الغاز
وهيدا اللي حصل وعملناه رغم الضيقه
الماليه اللي احنا فيها دفعنا مليون دولار
اذا بتذكر مضبوط لاصلاح هذا الخط وصولا
وبعدين قالوا لازم كمان اتفاقيات تكون
جاهزه وموقعه ومراجعه عاقبه للبنك الدولي
ومن قبل
الوزاره
الى المفاوضات وتوقيع المعاهدات
والاتفاقيات
اثنين بالكهرباء الاردنيه من حيث الانتاج
عفوا التوريد والنقل
بالغاز اللي هن كمان توريد ونقل عبر
الاردن وعامر سوريا مع تبادل سوريا كل هذا
تم مع الاتفاقيات وحتى اجوا الوزراء
والمدلاء مين المعاني في لبنان بيعده
مراحل لحتى وصلنا لبلوره هذه الاتفاقيات
ومافيا بالربيع 2000 20 بعد هذا الموضوع
كان في همم نايل ستون او نقطه محوريه هي
الاو سيميتينج الاو سي يعني اورجينايزن
كوميتي ميتنج تبع البنك الدولي كنت منتظر
انا في خلال هذا الاجتماع انه يحصل موافقه
على موضوع ادخال لبنان في مرحله مفاوضات
بهذه
البرنامج او هذه هاتين الاتفاقيتين كان ال
ال الراي انه نبدا بالاول بالغاز المصري
همم
اللي صار انه خلال الزياره تبع الوفد
البنك الدولي الفريق الدولي لا امريكا
خلال الزياره وبعد عودتهم يتبين انه ممكن
جاهزين لا يعطوا الموافق
ويبارك ان هو هناك اسئله كثيره لان هناك
الدول التي مستعد لتقديم الدعم تتحدث عن
الهيئه الناظمه التي لم تتشكل في لبنان
بسبب خلافات
الموضوع همم الموضوع اول شيء همم ما حكيو
انه التشكيله للهيئه العظمي قال له اطلاق
اطلاق ال- همم
الاجراء العمل اللي هو استدراج طلبات
الناس اللي عايز حابه تنتسب لهذه الهيئه
يعني اجراءات التوظيف بدايه
هنحكي عنه همم اول شغلي هذا الشرط بالاول
باول مرحله لحد الربيع ولحد الصيف 2002
و22 كان المفروض في سير بعد ما نكون دخلنا
في ال- المفاوضات وكان شرط لا تنفيذ ال-
همم التمويل اتفاقيه التمويل يعني ولا ليس
قبل الحصول على اتفاقيه التموين همم
واشتغلنا عنها الاساس بسلم الاولويات هلا
لما جينا وقالوا لنا بعد ما فتره البرود
بين الربيع والصيف رجعوا البنك الدولي
نشطوا حالهم شويه وقالوا لنا اذا اشتغلنا
على الشروط الاضافيين وهون برزولنا شرط
التعريفي كمان اللي كان لاحق اصبح سابق
اعمل ايه همم
اصبح ساريا من اول نوفمبر 2000 و22 وثاني
شرط كان موضوع اطلاق اجراءات توظيف الهيئه
المنظمي هون انا كنت بحاجه لشويه وقت لحتى
عملنا الصيغه المفيده واللي حسب الممارسات
المثلى يعمل فيها عالميا بموضوع الشكل
الهيئه النازمي من حيث الادوار الرئيسيه
لانه انا اذا بدنا نحنا نستدرج طلبيه
الناس لحتى نوظفهن بدنا نعرف كل واحد شو
اختصاصه والنبي افضل الناس كفاءه في هذا
الاختصار يعني عم تحكي في موضوع الفني
المعني بالطاقه والطاقه المتجدده عم تحكي
كمان الموضوع البيئي عم تحكي كمان الموضوع
الاقتصادي بيحدد السعر وغيره في وظائف
بامكانه
همم اجراءات تعيين هي الناظمي واعلن عنها
في الصحف بلبنان من حول كم يوم يعني قبل
نهايه الاسبوع اللي فات وايضا سنطلق كمان
اعلانات بالصحف الاجنبيين حتى الناس اذا
اللبنانيين او عرب او ذو كافئات ناس
بتحبيني ينتسبوا لل- همم يقدروا
يقدروا كمان طيب اسالوا على الاعلان لا
هنحطه في همم اوروبا وفي ال- ال- باللغه
الانجليزيه ايضا وفي بلاد العربي الوقت
يمر بسرعه والاسئله والاسيره كثيرا الان
دخلنا في مرحله التنقيب من قبل شريط توتال
نعم متى يبدا متى يبدا لبنان يستفيد من
اوكي هذا هو لازم تعريف
انا كان الي زيارتين مهمين لفرانسه وواحده
من سنه ووحده همم اليوم حصل فيهم لقاءات
مع رئيس تنفيذي لشركه تويوتا
بيظل عدم الاستقرار الامني بدون ضمانات
انه ملحي حدا يتعرض لنا ما فينا مباشر
بالتنقيب بالبلوك تسعه اللي هو محازي
للكيين من هذه الكلمه اما بزياره هذه اللي
حصلت اليوم بعد ان حصل الانجاز التاريخي
اللي هو متجسد بموضوع الترسيم واللي هو
حصلنا عليه من خلال المعادله اللي تم قوه
في لبنان همم سماحت لنا انه ناخذ المكسيما
من اللي بنقدر نحصل عليه بيظل ال- ال-
الامور اللي كانت حاصله لحد ذلك اليوم همم
شفت عنده همم التماست منه لا همم هالمره
همم رغبه حقيقي وقدره انه
ما في شروط هالمره عم بيحكي هالمره انه هو
مباشر بالاعمال والشركه الموضوع جدي جدا
وايضا تستعمل الى الكوميدي كاسيو يعني همم
تواصل مع الراي العام لحتى تعبر عن
الانجازات اللي عم تعملها لحتى يبين ال-
همم تطور العمل لانه هو بالنسبه له لبنان
في هذا الموضوع عنده المصلحه الكليه هي
مشتركه يعني اثنين يعني اهدافنا اصبحت مثل
بعض بهذا الملف المهم بدهم اسرع وقت ممكن
ينقضوا ويكتشفوا الغاز وينتجون ان شاء
الله هلا هون احكينا عن الجدول الزمني طيب
الجدول الزمني
وموضوع الحفارات خاصه موضوع حساس لانه في
كثير ناس عم تستعمل هذه الحفارات في سوء
الحفارات منو همم سهل لحد واحد يوصل عليه
عم بيقول لحتى نحصل على حفاره يعني بشكل
واقعي لازم ننتظر لا هو باشر بهذا بهذه
الاعمال استدراج عروض على الحفاره وانما
الحفاره متوقع تكون بين سبتمبر ونوفمبر
2022 انا كنت سامع هذا الحكي من فريق
بيروت ولكن همم حبيت اعمل زياره كرمال
اتاكد انه احنا بدنا ابكر من هذا الموضوع
هو قال حكي عن سبته وان شاء الله بيكون
ابكر حتى من سبته وان ما بيقدر يلتزم بشيء
قبل هذا الموضوع هلا اذا بسوق الحفارات
ليه اه لوحدي حفاره يعني تطلقت حفاره ممكن
تكون موجوده وعنده فتره زمنيه همم مش مش
عايزينه الطرف اللي عنده اياها ممكن
ناخدها منه او ياخدوها منه ويجيبوها ابكر
بس يعني عم نحكي همم هيدا منه البيسكيز
البيسكيز بيكون
بالخريف 2022,000 من هلا لو وقت
اول شيء زائده عدد الناس اللي بيشتغلوا
بهذا الموضوع
لهذه الحفاره فيه نهايه السنه يعني مفروض
خلال السنه 23 يكون خلص التنقيب وصلنا
النتيجه
هابدا لازم اول شيء مجلس ان هو يشتمه
ويكون جدي اكتر
بانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه بعد ذلك
يعني عم بيحاولوا ولكن ما عم يقدروا
يتوقفوا مجلس النواب مقسم بطريقه بلبنان
اليوم ما عم يقدروا يحصلوا على ال ال ال
العدد الكافي للمحافظه على النصاب بعد ذلك
العدد الكافي للاتيان برئيس الجمهوريه من
وراء النظام نفسه ما هو عيد الوضع هيد
الواقع هلا بتقول لي بعدها شيء لازم كمان
يصير في همم تسميه لرئيس وزراء وكمان لازم
بشكل جدي جدا يشكل همم مجلس الوزراء همم
وحكومه فاعله كامل لصلاحيات وبعد همم عم
تحكي التنقيب همم بس الحلو بالموضوع واللي
بيخليني ضل لانه كل الاعمال التحضيري اللي
لازم كانت عمل على المستوى الحكومي حتى
تتاهل تقدر تقوم
التحالف بخير انتم تعال عاملين اهو عاملين
لنا واخذنا فيها قرار من خلال دوله رئيس
الجنينه العون
همم وزير الطاقه وقع ومشيت يعني مشيت
السلك الثاني على السكه الصحيحه فهمنا
الموضوع سيد وليد فياض شكرا جزيلا